I've been asked like what's the worst
thing that's happened to me in as an
actor lots of things but I can't think
of something but it's constantly it's
constantly and I think there's always
something to overcome mostly within
myself I find actually it's never an
external thing it's usually something
I'm holding myself back or some fear
that I have of failure or rejection or
that's the auditioning process is
basically a process of being rejected
over and over and over and over again
until you either give up or something
breaks and you get you get an
opportunity but yeah it's having to have
a strong enough sense of oneself to keep
facing possible rejection and failure
that's that's that's that's every day
and that's the worst that's the worst
and the best because what it reveals to
you is that even after being rejected or
failing or falling flat on your face
that you don't die usually but you get
given an another level of kind of
confidence and awareness that things
don't fall apart actually and the
failure in rejection can be quite
wonderful and quite I don't know built
up your self-esteem and all in a weird
way I think of the worst thing there are
lots of this but most days there's like
a worse thing that happens but I'll do
better next time with that I'll have a
proper story and a funny story next time
[Music]
[Music]